tout l'été à la tombée du jour les
terrasses du château royal d'amboise
s'anime sous vos yeux une fresque
historique de la période gallo romaine
au 19e siècle en passant bien sûr par
l'âge d'or de la renaissance et depuis
quarante ans d'une génération à l'autre
des bénévoles passionnés enfilent leurs
costumes pour faire vivre ce moment
aurait dû renault les a suivis le temps
d'une soirée
tout commence à l'époque gallo romaine
puis le voyage est amorcée moyen âge
renaissance jusqu'à nos jours nous avons
rencontré les acteurs avant le début du
spectacle
tous bénévoles et amateurs certains
participent aux animations depuis des
années ici au château royal ça sort de
la routine de tasser n'est pas être
assis dans un fauteuil devant la télé
mais comme ça interactif aussi avec les
gens donc ça leur permet de participer
c'est très plaisant à faire c'est
intergénérationnel on s'amuse on passe
des moments alors des fois forcément il
ya deux-trois chez mémé sinon ce serait
pas drôle comme à la cour exactement
exactement ah bon choix c'est charles 8
dans son spectacle dès l'âge montant en
grade ma france en premier
l'association is loire d'amboise
orchestre le spectacle la centaine de
bénévoles jouent à tour de rôle dans
cette déambulation de nouvelles recrues
arrivent chaque jour c'est le cas de
christian qui a fait sa première la
semaine dernière beaucoup d'émotion et
beaucoup un petit peu d'improvisation
parce que bien sûr c'est au pied du mur
qu'on voit le maçon donc quand il a du
public c'est un peu différent niveau
ambiance mes sensations si on a peur de
se tromper on est appelés muet et de
l'émotion il y en a la petite chloé fête
aujourd'hui ses 9 ans en vacances en
touraine en famille elle fait de la
figuration pour un soir avec son arrière
grand mère je suis contente parce que
franchement
moi ça nous plaisait tellement et je
suis content que quelques achats de
vitesse parce que j'avais un peu peur
mais apparemment elle veut y aller
n'avons aujourd'hui et tu deviens
actrice
avec quoi bah ça fait un peu bizarre
mais ça va quand les acteurs bénévoles
partent en vacances l'association doit
les remplacer ainsi elle recherche des
figurants durant tout l'été
sur cette scène là il y en a certains
qui taille des pierres qui travaillent
le bois il ya des femmes qui déambulent
qui donne à voir aux ouvriers les
figurants devront faire une croix sur
leurs mercredis et samedis soirs mais
joueront dans un cadre royal